This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidhantham. All of us are time travelers. We go back in history to turning points in our lives and imagine how things could have turned out differently. What would have happened if we had chosen different paths, swiped right instead of left, moved abroad or quit smoking. This week on Hidden Brain, we'll tell you a story that shows when our minds reach for these alternate realities.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们所有人都是时间旅行者。我们回到历史中那些人生的转折点，想象事情本可以有不同的结局。如果我们当时选择了不同的道路，向右滑动而不是向左，搬到国外或者戒烟，事情会变成怎样？本周的Hidden Brain，我们将为您讲述一个故事，展现当我们的思维触及这些平行现实时的场景。
I am responsible because I didn't listen to him and what he was saying. And we'll also look at other scenarios where we're less likely to ask, what if? It turns out that the psychological forces that lead us to dream of alternate lives have profound effects on us and the planet. Laura Ogden has spent years imagining how things could have turned out differently. At the very start, she and her friends would go out to the mountains in Washington State. Going as fast as we can and going as steep as we can, starting to jump off rocks and challenge ourselves with our fear, I think that we came something I was drawn to and I guess addicted to as time went on.
我之所以有责任，是因为我没有听他的话，也没有听他当时在说些什么。我们还将探讨其他一些我们不太可能去思考“如果……会怎样？”的场景。事实证明，引导我们梦想另一种人生的心理力量，对我们自身和地球有着深远的影响。劳拉·奥格登花了很多年去想象事情本可以有不同的结局。最初，她和朋友们会去华盛顿州的群山中。尽可能快地滑，尽可能陡地滑，开始从岩石上跳跃，用恐惧挑战自我，随着时间的推移，我认为我被这种体验深深吸引，甚至可以说是上瘾了。
When she got to college, the whole ski culture opened up to me, so it snowballed. No pun intended from there. She moved from skiing resorts to wild slopes, where it was just her, some friends, and the elements. They'd hauled themselves to the top of mountains with skis on their backs, no ski lifts, no ski patrol, no cozy large with hot chocolate. Laura began to enter skiing competitions.
当她上大学时，整个滑雪文化向我敞开了大门，所以它像滚雪球一样发展开来。这话没有双关意指从那开始。她从滑雪度假村转移到了野外雪坡上，那里只有她、几个朋友和大自然。他们把滑雪板背在背上，艰难地爬上山顶，没有缆车，没有滑雪巡逻队，也没有提供热巧克力的舒适小屋。劳拉开始参加滑雪比赛。
She met a professional skier named Jack Hannan. Laura says skiing with someone can lead to a deep connection. It's like a landscape that can really conjure up a magic to it, awe-inspiring scenery. can really conjure up a magic to it, awe-inspiring scenery. You get up into these mountains and to be sharing that with somebody, it just hits you deeply
她遇到了一位名叫杰克·汉农的职业滑雪运动员。劳拉说，和某人一起滑雪能建立起深厚的联系。这就像一种能够真正唤起魔力的风景，令人惊叹的风景。能够真正唤起魔力的风景。当你来到这些群山之中，与某人分享这一切，这种感觉会深深击中心灵
and then sometimes it can be quite arduous like getting up to the top of a big peak. So you go through that suffering together for lack of a better word and then get this massive reward of skiing. It is almost like out of, it's an out of body experience in a way. Like this, this smooth ease of flow going down and you know that that person is having their own yet similar experience to you and that and that having that shared excitement together.
有时这也相当艰辛，比如爬上一个大山峰的顶峰。所以你们为了一个更好的词，一起经历那种痛苦，然后得到滑雪带来的巨大回报。这几乎就像是一种脱离肉体的体验。就像这种顺畅自如的下滑流动感，你知道那个人有着与你独特却又相似的体验，而且并且能够共同拥有这种兴奋感。
I mean, the rest is history. Laura and Jack got married in 2008. They bought a house on a big swath of land in the remote mountains of Canada. They planned to be home stethers and of course they would ski. Life was good. Going from day to day and not having too much to worry about besides where you're going to go skiing and is there you're going to have spaghetti for dinner or burritos because simple life. One day in March 2010, their friends Dave and Tessa treadway invited them to go skiing on Mount Curry.
我的意思是，剩下的就是历史了。劳拉和杰克于2008年结婚。他们在加拿大偏远山区买下了一片广阔土地上的房子。他们计划成为家园守护者，当然，他们也会滑雪。生活很美好。日复一日地过着，除了去哪里滑雪、晚饭是吃意大利面还是卷饼之外，没有太多需要担心的事，因为生活很简单。2010年3月的一天，他们的朋友戴夫和苔丝·特雷德韦邀请他们去库里山滑雪。
Dave and Tessa were also professional skiers. Dave had been out that week and found that conditions were good. So Laura and Jack said yes. The friends loaded their gear onto a helicopter that would drop them off at the top of the mountain. The pilot flew them to the top of Mount Curry, they got an old late start, instead of the usual 6 or 7 am, they made it to the top of the mountain around 11. The four friends tested the conditions by pushing a giant block of snow down the mountain. You're basically creating an avalanche ahead of you.
戴夫和苔丝也是职业滑雪运动员。戴夫那周去过那里，发现条件很好。于是劳拉和杰克答应了。朋友们把装备装上直升机，直升机将把他们放在山顶。飞行员把他们飞到库里山顶，他们出发得有点晚，不是通常的早上6点或7点，而是在11点左右才到达山顶。四个朋友通过把一块巨大的雪推下山来测试雪况。你基本上是在你前方制造一场雪崩。
So once you get on the snow to ski, it's much less likely that any avalanche underneath is going to happen again, because all that snow underneath you is consolidated. One by one, the friends began skiing. Tessa and I worked together, and then Jack had skied down to to us and then we were waiting for Dave to come down. We were kind of feeling like we were at the end of the more intense part and we're feeling pretty good and we're feeling like now it was time to go home basically. I know it was about 2.30 in the afternoon and I was kind of on the top of this this shoulder and I heard suddenly I heard Dave yelling at lunch.
所以一旦你踏上雪地滑雪，下面再次发生雪崩的可能性就会小得多，因为你脚下的所有雪都已经凝固了。朋友们一个接一个地开始滑雪。苔丝和我一起合作，然后杰克滑下来找到我们，接着我们在等戴夫滑下来。我们当时感觉就像是在最紧张的部分快要结束时，感觉挺不错的，觉得基本上是时候回家了。我知道当时大约是下午2点半，我差不多在这个山肩的顶部，我突然听到戴夫在大喊。
One thing I think is hard to imagine is just how heavy and forceful a whole bunch of snow can actually be. When it's coming down at 60 miles an hour, it's like a freight train. I just stood there, frozen. I didn't have anywhere safe that I could hunker down like a rock or a tree to hide behind, so I knew that there was nothing that I could do. Laura was not in the direct path of the avalanche. When it passed, she was still standing. There were clouds of fog around her. My yelled, Jack, and didn't hear anything. And then I yelled, Tessa, and she yelled back.
我认为有一点很难想象，那就是大量的雪实际上可以具有多么沉重和强大的力量。当它以每小时60英里的速度倾泻而下时，就像一列货运列车。我只是站在那里，惊呆了。我没有安全的地方可以像躲在岩石或树木后面那样蜷缩起来，所以我知道我什么也做不了。劳拉并不在雪崩的直接路径上。雪崩过去后，她依然站着。她周围弥漫着浓雾。我大喊，杰克，什么也没听到。然后我大喊，苔丝，她回应了我。
Dave called out that he was okay. But Jack? Laura and her friends took out their avalanche beacons. They knew that Jack's beacon would be broadcasting his location. If they picked up his signal, their devices would ping. Avalanche beacons are designed to ping faster. if rescuers get closer to a missing skier, they let metal detectors. Laura stared down the path of the Avalanche.
戴夫大喊他没事。但杰克呢？劳拉和她的朋友们拿出了他们的雪崩信标。他们知道杰克的信标会播报他的位置。如果他们接收到他的信号，他们的设备就会发出蜂鸣声。雪崩信标的设计使得救援人员越接近失踪滑雪者，就会发出更快的蜂鸣声，他们让金属探测器。劳拉凝视着雪崩的路径。
She and Dave took off down the mountain to find Jack, leaving Tessa as a lookout. side to look out. The avalanche was so big that it had taken most of the snow pack away and suddenly we were forced to ski down this terrain that was morally like alright I'm gonna hop over this rock and I'm gonna slide down this ice. Crazy how it was inconsequential like it wasn't a big deal for me. It was way more focused on we gotta go get Jack. So let's do what needs to be done. The avalanche beacon was telling me that I was basically a meter away from Jack's Evalanche Transceiver. But when she got to the spot, she could see nothing besides snow and ice and debris.
她和戴夫冲下山去寻找杰克，留苔丝担任瞭望员。在一旁望风。雪崩太大了，它带走了大部分积雪，突然我们被迫在这样的地形上滑雪，这简直就像是“好吧，我要跳过这块岩石，我要滑过这块冰”。疯狂的是，这微不足道，对我来说不是什么大事。我更专注于我们得去找杰克。所以让我们做该做的事。雪崩信标告诉我，我基本上距离杰克的雪崩收发器只有一米远。但当她到达那个地点时，除了雪、冰和残骸，她什么也看不见。
She dropped her knees. She got out her shovel and started to dig. The snow was so frozen and packed together that I couldn't really move the snow that way, so I had my ice axe. She hacked away at the snow back and I quickly discovered Jack's like the jacket he was wearing his shoulder so he wasn't very deep under the snow and I found him. She used her hands to claw away the snow. She needed to get to his face, to get him air. When I dug enough around his upper body and face,
她跪了下来。她拿出了铲子开始挖。雪冻得太结实了，聚在了一起，我没法那样铲雪，所以我拿出了冰镐。她对着积雪猛砍，很快就发现了杰克的夹克，他肩膀上穿的那件，所以他埋在雪里并不是很深，我找到了他。她用双手疯狂地扒开雪。她需要到达他的脸部，让他呼吸到空气。当我挖够了他上半身和脸部周围的雪时，
it started to dawn on me that he wasn't alive. What do you do in the minutes after you come to such a realization? What had just happened was not hitting me at all. I remember Tessa trying to talk to me was still on this version of autopilot. There was work to be done. They dug out a flat platform for a rescue helicopter to land. When they made it back down the mountain, Laura gave a statement to a police officer. I remember sitting in this little room with the RCMP officer and giving him details of what had happened, kind of like deadpan in a way, just stating the facts. And somehow I was able to describe to him
我开始意识到他已经不在了。在意识到这一事实后的几分钟里，你该做些什么？刚才发生的事情根本没有冲击到我。我记得苔丝试图跟我说话，我当时还在这种自动驾驶模式下。还有工作要做。他们挖出一个平坦的平台供救援直升机降落。当他们回到山下时，劳拉向一名警官作了陈述。我记得坐在皇家骑警警官的那个小房间里，向他提供发生的事情的细节，有点像是面无表情的方式，只是陈述事实。不知怎的，我能够向他描述
how my husband had just been killed by an avalanche. She kept it together until her best friend arrived. That's just when I lost it. I think I finally knew, or I don't really know. I just, I let it all go. But right as she started to break down, a voice in the back of her head reminded her of something that Jack had said that morning before they'd boarded the helicopter.
我的丈夫是如何刚刚死于雪崩的。她一直强撑着，直到她最好的朋友到来。就在那时我崩溃了。我想我终于知道了，或者我其实并不真正知道。我只是，我彻底释放了情绪。但就在她情绪崩溃的时候，她脑海深处的一个声音提醒了她一件事——那是杰克在登上直升机那天早上说过的话。
They'd been sitting in that truck. And Jack and I were by ourselves and looking at Mount Curry and Jack said to me, you know, I have a bad feeling about today. This was unusual. Jack was not a warrior. And when he didn't feel safe, he was an ambivalent. Jack's definitely been the one to say I'm not in two going out I'm going to pull the plug and he's adamant Laura asked him well if you have a bad feeling Do you think we should not go?
他们当时坐在那辆卡车里。杰克和我单独在一起，看着库里山，杰克对我说，你知道，我今天有种不好的预感。这很不寻常。杰克不是一个爱担心的人。当他觉得不安全时，他并非常常犹豫不决。杰克绝对是那种会说“我不想去，我要取消行程”并且态度坚决的人。劳拉问他，如果你有不好的预感，你觉得我们是不是不应该去？
And I I don't think he wanted to Be the one to say no, let's not go What did he say in response to you? He was slow to respond. I remember and said, well, no. We can still go. Laura couldn't bear to tell her friend about it.
而且我，我想他不想成为那个说“不，我们别去了”的人。他对你说了什么回应？我记得他反应迟钝，然后说，好吧，不。我们还是可以去。劳拉不忍心把这件事告诉她的朋友。
I felt really guilty. And I even have a little bit of shamefulness now admitting it that I'm responsible because I didn't listen to him and what he was saying. You know, it almost adds to the tragedy of it. Like, Jack had this feeling and we went anyway. Over and over, she replayed what had happened and imagined how things could have turned out differently. Laura's regret and pain are completely understandable.
我感到非常内疚。甚至现在承认这一点，我也感到有一点点羞耻，我觉得自己有责任，因为我没有听他的话，也没有听他当时在说些什么。你知道，这几乎加剧了这场悲剧。就像，杰克有这种预感，而我们还是去了。她一遍又一遍地回放发生的事情，想象事情本可以有不同的结局。劳拉的懊悔和痛苦是完全可以理解的。
Laura's regret and pain are completely understandable. Her reaction also reveals something important about how the mind works, how we process the past, and how we think about the future. When we think back on our lives, our minds tend to focus on specific events. We might imagine how things could have unfolded differently. We don't realize it, but there are psychological triggers that bring about these fantasies. Jack said to me. Years after Jack died, Laura still thinks about that day on Mount Curry. It's a video that plays on endless loop in her mind.
劳拉的懊悔和痛苦是完全可以理解的。她的反应也揭示了关于大脑如何运作、我们如何处理过去以及我们如何思考未来的重要信息。当我们回首人生时，我们的大脑往往会聚焦于特定的事件。我们可能会想象事情本可以有怎样不同的发展。我们没有意识到，正是这些心理触发因素带来了这些幻想。杰克对我说。杰克死后多年，劳拉依然会想起库里山上的那一天。那是一段在她脑海中无限循环播放的视频。
She keeps rewinding, pressing play. I have a bad feeling about today. I have a bad feeling about today. And then her mind changes the narrative, so Jack doesn't die. There's a technical name for this type of alternate reality, Account of Factual. Kathleen Rose studies how and why our minds produce these fantasies. She's a psychologist at the University of Minnesota. Account of Factual is a mental simulation where you think about what did happen, so some
她不断地倒带，按下播放键。我今天有种不好的预感。我今天有种不好的预感。然后她的脑海改变了叙事，杰克没有死。这种类型的平行现实有一个专业名称：反事实（Counterfactual）。凯瑟琳·沃斯研究我们的大脑如何以及为什么会产生这些幻想。她是明尼苏达大学的心理学家。反事实是一种心理模拟，你思考实际发生了什么，也就是某个
event led to another event. And then you think about what did happen. So some event led to another event. And then you think of an alternate ending. For example, if you drive home from work today and you get into a car accident, that would be terrible. And you may start thinking about why that happened. If you took a new route home from work, one of the counterfactuals may be, now if only I had stuck to my usual way of going home, maybe this wouldn't have happened. Laura's counterfactual looks like this. She and Jack sit in that truck looking up at Mount Curry.
事件导致了另一个事件。然后你思考实际发生了什么。所以某个事件导致了另一个事件。然后你想想一个不同的结局。例如，如果你今天下班开车回家时遭遇了一场车祸，那将是可怕的。你可能会开始思考为什么会发生这种事。如果你走了条新的下班路线，其中一个反事实可能是：要是我今天坚持走平时回家的路，也许就不会发生这种事了。劳拉的反事实是这样的：她和杰克坐在那辆卡车里，抬头望着库里山。
Jack says, You know, I have a bad feeling about today. And Laura says, Well then I think we should listen to your bad feeling and trust that intuition and not go Jack lives Laura's world remains intact The reason Laura comes up with this alternate ending is because she wants it to be true At the same time she knows these thoughts aren't very useful. She can't bring her husband back
杰克说：“你知道，我今天有种不好的预感。”劳拉说：“那我觉得我们应该听从你的不祥预感，相信那种直觉，不要去了。”杰克活了下来，劳拉的世界完好无损。劳拉之所以会想出这个不同的结局，是因为她希望这是真的。与此同时，她知道这些想法并没有什么用。她无法让她的丈夫复活。
So why does her mind keep producing these thoughts? It turns out there are specific elements to the story that invite counterfactual thinking. To understand what they are, meet Neil Rose. I'm a professor of marketing at the Kellogg School of Management at Northwestern University. Neil has found four triggers for counterfactual thinking. One, a clearly bad outcome. When I dug enough around his upper body and face, it started to dawn on me that he wasn't alive. Just seeing something negative or something that falls short of expectations, that tends to bring counterfactuals to mind. Two, something happened that was out of the ordinary.
所以为什么她的脑海不断产生这些想法？事实证明，故事中存在着特定的元素，会引发反事实思维。为了解这些元素是什么，请认识尼尔·罗斯。我是西北大学凯洛格管理学院的市场营销教授。尼尔发现了反事实思维的四个触发因素。第一，一个明显糟糕的结果。当我挖够了他上半身和脸部周围的雪时，我开始意识到他已经不在了。仅仅是看到消极的事情，或者低于预期的事情，往往会让人联想到反事实。第二，发生了意料之外的事情。
I'd never heard Jack say this before, that he was like, you know, I have a bad feeling about today. The husband's saying that he has a bad feeling about it. Presumably, that's a rare occurrence, but it was significant on that moment. It becomes more significant after the fact, of course, but it's unusual. And so our thoughts very naturally gravitate toward that unusual aspect. Three, you can see how you yourself or some other person played a central role in what happened.
我从未听杰克说过这样的话，他当时说，你知道，我今天有种不好的预感。丈夫说他有不好的预感。据推测，这是一种罕见的情况，但在那个时刻却意义重大。当然，事后看来它变得更具意义了，但这并不寻常。因此，我们的思绪非常自然地被这个不同寻常的方面所吸引。第三，你能看到你自己或其他人在事件的发展中扮演了核心角色。
I'm responsible because I didn't listen to him and what he was saying. Four, you can draw a direct connection between what someone did or didn't do and the negative thing that happened. Cause and effect are close together. We look at actions that are relatively close to a key outcome. In other words, maybe a few minutes before or even a few hours before, but not years in the past. So Laura doesn't rewind the tape so far back that she questions why she became a skier.
我之所以有责任，是因为我没有听他的话，也没有听他当时在说些什么。第四，你可以将某人做了什么或没做什么与发生的消极事情之间建立直接联系。原因和结果紧密相连。我们关注的是与关键结果相对接近的行为。换句话说，可能是几分钟前甚至几小时前，而不是多年前的过去。所以劳拉不会把磁带倒回那么远，去质疑自己当初为什么要成为一名滑雪者。
As Kathleen Vose points out, she rewinds the story to the conversation in the truck. There is a moment where they discuss doing something different. The counterfactual is just so salient for her story and she along with Jack made a different decision and then here we are. Counterfactuals don't exist just to drive us crazy. We engage in this kind of thinking for a reason. Interfactual thoughts are generally useful for us in terms of providing a set of options that
正如凯瑟琳·沃斯所指出的，她把故事倒回到了卡车里的那段对话。在那个时刻，他们讨论了做一些不同的事情。这个反事实对于她的故事来说是如此显眼，她和杰克做出了一条不同的决定，然后我们便落入了这般田地。反事实的存在并不是为了把我们逼疯。我们进行这种思考是有原因的。反事实思维对我们来说通常是有用的，它提供了一系列选择，
we might act upon in the future. And this can lead to improvement, it can lead to learning from experience. When we go back and revisit a decision that turned out poorly, when we imagine how we could have made a different decision, it can be painful. But it can also be very useful. It can help us see how, if the same kind of situation rolls around again, we could do something different next time. There's a second reason counterfactuals are psychologically useful. When something bad happens, kind of shakes your confidence that you understand the world
我们未来可能会根据这些选择采取行动。这可以带来改进，可以让我们从经验中吸取教训。当我们回过头来重新审视一个结果糟糕的决定时，当我们想象自己本可以做出不同的决定时，这可能会很痛苦。但它也非常有用。它能帮助我们看到，如果将来再次出现类似的情况，下一次我们可以采取不同的做法。反事实在心理上有用的第二个原因在于：当糟糕的事情发生时，它会动摇你对理解这个世界的信心，
and you can predict what's going to happen. And so when people engage in counterfactuals and they simulate other alternate pathways, if I've done this differently, then this negative thing may not have occurred, gives them some sense of control that they understand the world more, and that can help in a psychological sense be a very adaptive pattern. This is all healthy. We turn bad things that happen into lessons for the future. And by imagining how we could have changed what happened,
动摇你对即将发生的事情的预测能力。因此，当人们进行反事实思考并模拟其他平行的发展路径（“如果我当初换个做法，这种消极的事情也许就不会发生”）时，这会赋予他们一种掌控感，让他们觉得自已对世界的理解加深了，从心理学角度来看，这可以成为一种极具适应性的模式。这一切都是健康的。我们将发生的坏事转化为未来的教训。通过想象我们本可以如何改变已经发生的事情，
we get a feeling of control and agency. Counterfactuals become a driver of change, of action. Of course, this leads to the question, what happens when events do not set off counterfactual thinking? As Neil shows, there are specific features in a story that cause our minds to come up with alternate versions. Without those triggers, we don't engage in counterfactuals. And without counterfactuals, we're often not inclined to change our behavior. This relationship between counterfactuals and behavior made me think about a conversation I had a few years back, and it brings us to a second scenario we want to explore today.
我们获得了控制感和自主权。反事实成为了变革和行动的推动力。当然，这就引出了一个问题：当事件没有触发反事实思维时会发生什么？正如尼尔所展示的，故事中的某些特定特征会导致我们的大脑产生平行版本。如果没有这些触发因素，我们就不会进行反事实思考。而如果没有反事实思考，我们往往就不会倾向于改变自己的行为。反事实与行为之间的这种联系让我想起了几年前的一次对话，这也把我们带到了今天想要探讨的第二个场景。
I was visiting the Mendenhall Glacier in Alaska. We did an episode about it some time ago. The glacier is a dazzling sight, but it's also a bleak lesson in climate change. It's receded dramatically in a matter of decades. As I was telling it a viewing point, Terry Lambert, visiting from Southern California, came up beside me. We both stared at the wall of ice in the distance.
当时我正在访问阿拉斯加的门登霍尔冰川。不久前我们做过一期关于它的节目。这座冰川景色耀眼，但它也是一堂关于气候变化的残酷课程。在几十年的时间里，它急剧退缩。正当我站在观景台时，从南加州来访的特里·兰伯特走到了我旁边。我们一齐凝视着远处的冰墙。
I introduced myself. I'm wondering if I might talk with ice in the distance. I introduce myself. I'm wondering if I might talk with you for a moment. I'm a journalist. I work for NPR in Washington. And ask him what he made of the Glacier's retreat. The Glacier's a lot of it gets replaced every year when it snows. It might be receding in, but we're still going to have snow. We're still going to get some replaced. So I just think it's, I mean, as old as they are, it's, they can't last forever.
我做了自我介绍。我想知道我能否远处的冰墙。我自我介绍。我想知道我能否跟你聊一会儿吗？我是一名记者。我在华盛顿的NPR工作。并询问他对冰川退缩的看法。冰川每年下雪时会有很大一部分得到补充。它可能在退缩，但我们仍然会有雪。我们仍然会得到一些补充。所以我只是觉得，我的意思是，不管它们有多古老，它们不可能永远存在。
Yeah, it's receding faster, but what are you going to do? What are you going to do? I thought back to that conversation with Terry in the context of Laura's story. Unlike Laura, Terry wasn't bothered by counterfactual thoughts. He didn't say, if only humans hadn't burned so much fossil fuel, maybe the glacier wouldn't have receded. He didn't say, what could I have done to head off climate change? Surveys have found that about half of all Americans don't worry that much about a warming planet. Psychologists Neil Rose and Kathleen Rose think that our responses to challenges like climate change might be very different
是的，它退缩得更快了，但你能怎么办呢？你能怎么办呢？在劳拉的故事背景下，我想到了与特里的那次对话。与劳拉不同，特里并没有被反事实的想法所困扰。他没有说：“要是人类当初没有燃烧那么多化石燃料，也许冰川就不会退缩了。”他没有说：“我本可以做些什么来阻止气候变化？”调查发现，大约一半的美国人不那么担心地球变暖。心理学家尼尔·罗斯和凯瑟琳·沃斯认为，我们对气候变化等挑战的反应，可能会非常不同
from our responses to a skiing accident because climate change doesn't have the four triggers that set off counterfactual thinking. Take what Terry told me, for instance, he didn't see what was happening to the glacier as something negative. Even if it all melts, it's not going to be the end of the world. There could be changes, some species could be advantage, some species could be
于我们对滑雪事故的反应，因为气候变化并不具备引发反事实思维的四个触发因素。以特里对我说的话为例，他并不认为冰川发生的事情是消极的。即使它全部融化，也不会是世界末日。可能会有变化，某些物种可能会受益，某些物种可能会
disadvantage, the ecosystem is changing, you're going to have flooding, you could have weather events, right? There could be consequences that affect you and I? Yes, but like I say, it's so far in the future, I'm not worried about it. Two, counterfactuals are triggered when you can see something happen that's out of the ordinary. Terry doesn't see anything unusual about the receding glacier. You know, everything goes around in circles, I guess.
受损，生态系统正在改变，你可能会遭遇洪水，你可能会经历极端天气，对吧？可能会产生影响你我的后果？是的，但正如我所说，那太遥远了，我不担心。第二，当你能看到不寻常的事情发生时，反事实就会被触发。特里并没有觉得冰川退缩有什么不寻常的地方。你知道，万物都在周而复始，我想。
So, you know, it starts at one place and goes back to the beginning and at some point. So not in my lifetime, but I'm sure at some point we'll probably have another ice age. Three, counterfactual spring to mind when you can see how you yourself or some other person played a central role in what happened. In Terry's case, I personally don't think it's something that man's doing to make in that melt. And four, seeing a direct connection between an outcome and what someone did or didn't do tends to produce counterfactuals.
所以，你知道，它从一个地方开始，然后回到起点，在某个时刻。所以不是在我有生之年，但我确信在某个时刻我们可能会再次迎来冰河时代。第三，当你能看到你自己或其他人在事件的发展中扮演了核心角色时，反事实就会浮现在脑海。就特里的情况而言，我个人不认为那是人类导致冰川融化的原因。第四，看到结果与某人做过或没做过的事情之间存在直接联系，往往会产生反事实。
Causing effect need to be side by side. In the case of climate change, the causes are diffused and distant and the worst effects have not yet happened. Obviously, even if you accept the reality of climate change, you can't lay the responsibility for it at the feet of any one person. The key difference between these two different stories is the immediacy of the negative outcome. It's something either very abrupt and very, very severe that happens to you at a particular moment versus something that unfolds more generally, more slowly and is not that much of a direct
原因和结果需要并驾齐驱。在气候变化的情况下，原因分散且遥远，最坏的影响尚未发生。显然，即使你承认气候变化的现实，你也不能将责任归咎于某一个人。这两个不同故事之间的关键核心区别在于负面结果的即时性。这是你在特定时刻遭遇的某种非常突然且非常严重的事情，而相对的则是某种展开得更全面、更缓慢、对你的生活没有那么直接冲击的事情。
impact on your life. So the difference between these two is that the first one will activate a lot of counterfactual thoughts focusing on your own action. The second one is just more diffuse and perhaps is going to be involved with a bit more fatalism, just feeling like, well, this is the way things are and there's not much I can do. If counterfactual thinking tends to lead us to act, an absence of counterfactual thinking can keep us from seeing what we can do. While it's just like earthquakes and floods and hurricanes,
所以这两者之间的区别在于，第一种会激活大量聚焦于你自身行动的反事实想法。第二种则更加分散，也许会涉及更多宿命论的色彩，只会觉得：“嗯，事情就是这样，我也无能为力。”如果反事实思维倾向于驱使我们采取行动，那么缺乏反事实思维则会让我们看不到自己能做些什么。虽然这就像地震、洪水和飓风一样，
there are just all part of what's going on. You can't control it, you can't change it. The retreat of the Mendenhall Glacier is not in itself proof of climate change. But when scientists zoom out and look at all the data, their consensus is that climate change is happening and that its consequences are all around us. Human actions are tied to the problems that have already struck. Human inaction is directly implicated in the disasters that are to come. Kathleen Rose says, from a psychological perspective, the difficulty in coming up with counterfactuals for climate change
它们都只是正在发生的事情的一部分。你无法控制它，你也无法改变它。门登霍尔冰川的退缩本身并不是气候变化的证据。但当科学家们缩小视野、审视所有数据时，他们的共识是气候变化正在发生，其后果就在我们身边。人类的行动与已经发生的灾难息息相关。人类的不作为则与即将到来的灾难有着直接的牵连。凯瑟琳·沃斯表示，从心理学的角度来看，在气候变化问题上很难产生反事实，
can easily produce apathy. I don't really know what kind of a role each and every one of us plays and all of that. And so it makes her just a psychologically very kind of messy understanding of who's responsible, what should we do? And it's very hard to understand the results or even know when they may come about. They may not even come about in our lifetimes, which makes it even more psychologically remote. In Laura's case, she can see the one specific thing
这很容易导致冷漠。我真的不知道我们每个人在其中扮演了什么样的角色。因此，这使得人们在心理上对谁该负责、我们该做什么产生了一种非常混乱的理解；而且很难理解结果，甚至很难知道它们何时会到来。它们甚至可能不会在我们有生之年到来，这使得它在心理上更加遥远。在劳拉的例子中，她能看到那件具体的事情，
she could have done to prevent Jack's death. But... It's very hard to see a cause and effect relationship to, you know, throwing another soda can in the recycling bin and seeing the temperature of the oceans not rise nearly as fast. Not all environmental problems are like climate change. Some do trigger counterfactual thinking, and these lead us to act. Terry Lambert wasn't worried about climate change, but when there was an environmental problem close to home, one that was wiping out a species of mollusks, he literally came to the rescue. He used to dive off the Anacapa Islands in California.
那是她本可以做来阻止杰克死亡的事。但是……要看到因果关系是非常困难的，比如，把另一个苏打罐头扔进回收箱，然后眼看海洋温度上升的速度没有那么快。并非所有环境问题都像气候变化那样。有些确实会触发反事实思维，而这些思维会引导我们采取行动。特里·兰伯特并不担心气候变化，但当家门口出现环境问题——一种正在消灭某种软体动物的问题时，他真的挺身而出进行救援。他过去常常在加利福尼亚州的阿纳卡帕群岛附近潜水。
They were having a problem with the black avaloni being extinct and some of it. And I did several dives and helped replace the avaloni. We built habitat form and put them in there. So the local environment, yeah, I've had my hands on it. You know, you do what you can do. You do what you can do. That's pretty much the opposite of what he said about the shrinking glacier. Yeah, it's receding faster, but what are you going to do?
黑鲍鱼面临着灭绝的问题，其中一部分是这样。我进行了几次潜水，帮助恢复鲍鱼的数量。我们为它们建造了栖息地并将它们放了进去。所以对于当地的环境，是的，我曾亲自动手。你知道，你能做多少就做多少。你尽力而为。这几乎与他关于冰川缩小的言论完全相反。是的，它退缩得更快了，但你能怎么办呢？
It's telling that Terry felt compelled to do something about the local issue. He could see his role in the solution. This might be a hint at a way around the kings and our counterfactual thinking. If unconscious rules keep us from thinking about counterfactuals when they could be useful, we might have to consciously choose to open the door to these thoughts. I think it's just a simple conversational style where you could just directly ask, what could you personally have done differently? How could you have made things better? How could you have made things better?
耐人寻味的是，特里觉得有必要对当地的问题采取行动。他能看到自己在解决方案中扮演的角色。这或许暗示了一种绕过我们反事实思维阻碍的方法。如果无意识的规则阻止我们在反事实有用时去思考它们，我们可能就必须有意识地选择为这些想法打开大门。我认为这只是一种简单的对话风格，你可以直接询问：你个人本可以做出什么不同的改变？你本可以如何让事情变得更好？你本可以如何让事情变得更好？
How could you have performed a more positive action? And so I think it is a reasonable thing to bring up on a conversation. Other times, we may need to talk ourselves out of engaging in counterfactuals. For Laura, it does make a great deal of sense that she's doing that, although, of there's there's really no way that she has culpability or responsibility here.
你本可以如何采取更积极的行动？所以我认为在对话中提出这一点是合理的事情。其他时候，我们可能需要说服自己不要沉溺于反事实。对于劳拉来说，她那样做是非常合情合理的，尽管，实际上她在这里真的没有任何过错或责任。
My journey definitely continues. I definitely was taking less risk and skiing much more conservatively, but I still had such powerful connections with the mountains because that's where I connected the jack. Like every useful feature in the brain, counterfactuals don't always bring to mind when they're needed. Sometimes they show up when they're not useful, and they produce unnecessary pain. Other times, they fail to appear, fostering apathy. Sometimes, the path you wish you'd pursued
我的旅程绝对仍在继续。我确实在减少冒险，以更加保守的方式滑雪，但我与群山之间依然有着如此强烈的联系，因为那里是我与杰克建立联系的地方。就像大脑中的每一个有用功能一样，反事实并不总是在需要时浮现。有时它们会在没有用处的时候出现，从而产生不必要的痛苦。而另一些时候，它们未能出现，从而助长了冷漠。有时，你希望自己走过的那条路，
is just a mirage. Other times, there was a turn you needed to take, all you had to do was see it. This week's show was produced by Raina Cohen and Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarral. We also bid a fawn goodbye this week to our incredible intern, Camilla Vargas Restrepo. Camilla is one of those rare people whose talent and drive are coupled with a truly kind and caring nature. Thank you, Kimmelah, for all that you brought to Hidden Brain.
不过是海市蜃楼。而另一些时候，那是你必须转弯的地方，你所要做的只是看见它。本期节目由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和帕斯·沙阿（Path Shah）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和劳拉·夸拉尔（Laura Quarral）。本周，我们还要深情告别我们出色的实习生卡米拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Camilla Vargas Restrepo）。卡米拉是那种罕见的人，她的才华和进取心与真正善良关爱的天性完美结合。谢谢你，卡米拉，感谢你为Hidden Brain带来的一切。
And thanks also for those amazing little coconut treats you brought us from Bogota. We're gonna miss you. Our unsung hero this week is Carlos Chavez on NPR's IT AppStame. A few weeks ago, we were trying to publish our podcast and the computer we were using crashed. Rebooting it didn't help. The software simply wouldn't mix down our episode. Carlos spent hours on the phone with us, troubleshooting the problem and brainstorming solutions.
也感谢你从波哥大带给我们那些美味的小椰子点心。我们会想念你的。本周我们的幕后英雄是NPR的IT应用团队的卡洛斯·查韦斯（Carlos Chavez）。几周前，我们正试图发布我们的播客，结果我们使用的电脑崩溃了。重新启动并没有用。软件就是无法混音导出我们的单集。卡洛斯花了好几个小时跟我们通电话，排查问题并集思广益寻找解决方案。
When inanimate computer programs inexplicably stop working, having a human around to lend a sympathetic ear can make everything a lot easier. Thank you Carlos. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. Thank you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当没有生命的计算机程序莫名其妙地停止工作时，身边有个能倾听并给予同理心的人会让一切变得容易得多。谢谢你，卡洛斯。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。谢谢你。你目前还没有针对此本集的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。